what is a digital asset what is monetary
why use those terms versus the words of
money and and currency is there
something interesting in that
disambiguation of different terms
i'd call it a crypto asset network
the goal is to create
a billion dollar block
of pure energy in cyberspace
one that i could that i could then move
with no friction at the speed of light
right it's it's the equivalent to
putting a million pounds in orbit
how do i actually
launch
something into orbit right how do i
launch something into cyberspace that
such that it moves friction free and the
solution
is a you know decentralized
proof-of-work network right satoshi's
solution was
i'm going to establish protocol running
on a distributed set of computers
that will maintain a constant supply of
never more than 21 million bitcoin
subdividable by a hundred million
satoshis each
transferable
via transferring private keys
now
the innovation
is uh
to create that in a
ethical
durable
fashion
right the the ethical innovation is i
want it to be property and not a
security
a bushel of corn
an acre of land a stack of lumber and a
bar of gold
and a bitcoin are all property and that
means they're all
commonly occurring elements in the world
you could call them commodities but
commodity is a little bit misleading and
i'll tell you why in a second
but they're all distinguished by the
fact that no one entity or person or
government controls them
if you have a barrel of oil
and you're in ukraine versus russia
versus saudi arabia versus the us
you have a barrel of oil
right and it doesn't matter what the
premier in in japan
or the mayor of miami beach thinks about
your bill they cannot wave their hand
and make it not a barrel of oil or a
cord of wood right
and so property is just a naturally
occurring element in the universe
right
why use the word ethical and sorry to i
may interrupt occasionally
why why ethical assigned to property
because if it's a security a security
would be an example of a share of a
stock
or a crypto token controlled by a small
team
and and in the event that something is a
security because
some small group or some identifiable
group can control its nature character
supply
then
it really only becomes ethical to
promote it or sell it pursuant to fair
disclosures
so i'll give you maybe practical example
i'm the mayor of chicago
i give a speech
my speech i say i think everybody in
chicago should own their own farm
and have chicken a chicken in the
backyard and their own horse and an
automobile
that's ethical
i give the same speech and i say i think
everybody in chicago should buy twitter
stock
sell their house or sell their cash and
buy twitter stock
well is that ethical
not really but at that point you've
entered into a conflict of interest
because what you're doing is you're
promoting um an asset
which is substantially controlled by a
small group of people the board of
directors or the ceo of the company so
if you know how would you feel if the
president united states said i really
think americans should all
buy apple stock
you would you know especially if you
work at google or but you worked
anywhere you'd be like why isn't he
saying buy mine
right a security is um
is a proprietary asset in some way shape
or form the and the whole nature of
securities law it starts from this
ancient
ancient idea thou shalt not lie cheat or
steal
okay
so
if
if i'm going to sell you securities or
i'm going to promote securities as a
public figure or as an influencer or
anybody else
right if
if i create my own yo-yo coin or
mikeycoin and then there's a million of
them
and i tell you that i think that it's a
really good thing and mikeycoin will go
up forever
right nobody buys mikeycoin and then i
give 10 million to you and don't tell
the public right i've cheated them
maybe if if i have mikeycoin and i think
there's only two million mikey coin and
i swear to you there's only two million
and then i get married and i have three
kids and my third kid is in the hospital
and my kid's gonna die and i have this
ethical reason to print five hundred
thousand more mikey coin or else people
are going to die and everybody tells me
it's fine
you know i've still abused you know the
investor right it's
it's a ethical challenge
if you look at um ethics laws
um everywhere in the world
uh they all boil down to having a clause
which says that if you're a public
figure you can't endorse
any a security you can't endorse
something that would cause you to have a
conflict of interest
so if you're a mayor a governor a
country a public figure an influencer
and you want to promote or promulgate or
support something using any public
influence or funds or resources you may
have
it needs to be property it can't be
security
so
it goes beyond that right i mean like
would the chinese want to support an
american company
right as soon as you look at what's in
the best interest of the human race the
civilization
you realize that
if you want an ethical path forward
it needs to be based on
common property
which is fair
and the way you get to a common property
is through an open permissionless
protocol
if it's not open right if it's
proprietary and i know what the code
says and you don't know what the code
says that's that makes it a security
if uh
if it's uh permissioned
if you're not allowed on my network or
if you can be censored or booted off my
network
that also makes it a security
um
so
so when i talk about uh
property i mean
the challenge here is how do i create
something that's equivalent to a barrel
of oil
in cyberspace
and that means it has to be a a
non-sovereign bearer instrument open
permissionless not censorable
right
if i could do that
then i could deliver you 10 000
dematerialized barrels of oil
and you would take settlement of them
and you would know that you have
possession of that property irregardless
of the opinion of any politician or any
company or anybody else in the world
uh that that's a a really critical
characteristic and and it actually is
it's probably one of the fundamental
things that makes bitcoin special
bitcoin isn't just a crypto asset
network it's easy to create a crypto
asset network it's very hard
uh to create an ethical
crypto asset network because
you ha you have to create one
without any government or corporate
corporation or investor exercising into
influence to make it successful
you